من جت قال المتحدث باسم البنتاجون بات
رايدر ان الضربات ضد اهداف الحوثيين في
اليمن رساله واضحه مفادها انه لن يتم
التسامح مع هجماتهم واضاف رايدر في مقابله
مع شبكه س ان ان ان الضربات استهدفت منشات
تضم رادارات وصواريخ ومسيرات تابعه
للحوثيين نفذنا عمليه مهمه ومتعدده
الجنسيات في رساله واضحه الحوثيين مفادها
انه لن يتم التسامح مع انواع الهجمات التي
يشنون منذ 19 نوفمبر الماضي الضربات التي
نفذناها استهدفت على وجه التحديد المنشات
التي يعتقد انها تضم ردارات وصواريخ
وقدرات للمسيرات التي مكنت الحوثيين من
تنفيذ
هجماتهم اذهب اليك عبد الفتاح وبالرغم من
ان بايدن كان تحدث عن ان لا لا حمايه
للحوثيين في هذه الاستهدافات وانه سيتم
الرد بشكل قوي لانه في ذات الوقت كان يؤكد
قبل ايام انه لا يريد احتواء الحوثيين
وانما فقط حمايه الملاحه هذه معادله كيف
يتم التعامل معها ليس فقط على مستوى
الخطابات ولكن ايضا فيما يتعلق بهذه
الخطوات التي قامت بها الان الولايات
المتحده ايه بالفعل مياده وهذا هو الجدل
الدائر الان على الساحه الامريكيه والذي
يظهر بوضوح في تصريحات لمسؤولين امريكيين
سواء ذكروا اسمائهم او لم يذكروا اسمائهم
اسمائهم عفوا يتحدثون عن ان الرئيس جو
بايدن تعرض لضغوط شديده لكي يقوم بشن هذه
الضربات الى الحوثيين وان الرئيس بايدن قد
تاخر كثيرا في اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار لانه
كان يريد ان يعطي الخيارات الدبلوماسيه
الاولويه لاحتواء تلك الخيارات ويشيرون في
ذلك الى جوله وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انوني بلينكن في المنطقه طقه وان هدف هذه
الجوله كان هو محاوله احتواء مثل هذه
الضربات وتاخير وتاجيل تنفيذ مثل هذه
الضربات لكن في الوقت نفسي يقول المسؤولين
الامريكيون انهم كانوا يضغطون على الاداره
الامريكيه للقيام بتلك العمليه نظرا ل ما
يصفونه بالهجمات المتهوره وغير المشروعه
لجماعه الحوثي في البحر الاحمر والتهديدات
التي لا تتعرض لها فقط الملاحه الدوليه
ولكن ايضا تشكل خطرا على القوات الامريكيه
وقوات التحالف في المنطقه وبالتالي كان
لابد من ان يكون هناك رساله واضحه
للحوثيين انه لن يتم التسامح مع تلك
الهجمات وانهم قد تجاوزوا الخطوط الحمراء
قال ذلك المسؤولون في البيت الابيض
المتحدث عفوا المسؤولون في البنتاجون
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بات
رايدر وايضا ذكره وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ايضا انطوني لويد اوستين وكذلك ذكر على
لسان اكثر من مسؤول امريكي وقائد عسكري
امريكي سواء في القياده المركزيه الوسطى
او ايضا في قائد القوات الجويه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط جميعهم تحدثوا عن ان الحوثي
قد تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء وان هذه الضربات
ليست سوى رساله الى جماعه انصار الله
الحوثي
والى ايران كدوله راعيه لهم كما يشيرون
دائم
رعاتهم الايرانيون كما يقولون وكما قالوا
في تصريحاتهم هي رساله لهم بانه لن يتم
التسامح مع مثل تلك التهديدات وتلك
الهجمات مستقبلا كانت هناك ما يدى اشارات
دائمه الى محاوله الفصل بين هذه الضربات
وبين الحرب في غزه انه لا علاقه بينها
بينهما كانت هناك ايضا محاولات للفصل بين
تلك الضربات التي قامت بها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا تحديدا وبين
التحالف الذي تقوده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه باسم حارس الازدهار وان هذه
الضربات لا تمثل هذا التحالف وعلى ما يبدو
كان في ذلك محاوله لحمايه الشركاء
الاقليميين المنضوين في عضويه هذا التحالف
وايضا الشركاء الدوليين وقصر المسؤوليه
على القوات الامريكيه والقوات البريطانيه
فقط وبالتالي ردود الافعال مياده ما زالت
تتواصل شعبيا بمظاهرات كانت ليليه اليوم
امام البي الابيض ومظاهرات ربما مرتقبه
غدا ومظاهرات يتم الدعوه اليها بشكل كبير
يوم السبت المقبل الى جانب ردود الافعال
المرتقبه من جانب الفعاليات السياسيه
والنيابي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
طبعا مياد